welcome to this video playing combo man
combo man okay okay f2 against a
sicilian okay this is an interesting
line actually but normally you do when
you take on d5 this now is just a
terracon mm carol can advance with with
extra move so a 3 uh-huh yeah I don't
know looks kind of weird t3
yeah okay this is one of those games by
you at one point just have to play moves
because the other guy will never play
move that you expect yeah if he goes a 3
C 3 and this kind of stuff just play
quickly it is useless to think about
what you might play because you never
expect a move okay night comes to f5 and
I'm getting c5 back and I have a huge
development advantage he has played pawn
moves almost exclusively so looks looks
quite nice that is mentioned I mean you
never know what he's going to do wake
you hit okay it's probably probably a
good move trying to keep keep the
position known as close as possible
okay 27 just normal looking maybe ok I
can go I can play play 93 not sure about
the move it's not bad but is there
something better I don't know let's play
it not coming to a huge time pressure
here possible 22 really that looks a bit
accommodating 94 is not exactly rocket
science I had to play King move King
King g1 or something and well
uncertainly in good shape but not as
good as I'm here so eat where winds
winds huge chunks of material try to
ignite a 3 double check and the rook and
everything check
okay huge chunks of material means that
means a piece just a piece so maybe I
could have could have one more material
it felt like that should be more even
but this is this is not bad of course
okay so much am I have some attacking
ideas as well on the G file Luke g3 or
something rg7 I don't know just a
difference Roach can just take it you
can just take it what am i doing yeah
what do you buy doing you can just take
this rope ah ah yeah yeah yeah of course
you can take it ah but what the heck
what thick okay i can i can get
something back here probably but this is
toto to today I just play group g3 what
did I do haha ah I route g3 I just I'm
just a piece up in this position
unbelievable stuff I mean I've done my
fair share of stupid moves but this is
really great this is really great I just
played route III and he took it amazing
really amazing wow what is this equal
material around oh my god after this
justice after this industry moves it's
really hard to believe hope she's free
I've I don't know what I was thinking
when group g 7 is just a piece for
nothing okay yeah I just just continue
here and see what what's going maybe I
can still do something check you this
may maybe this is too risky and what I'm
trying possible right okay well after
route 23 a really great check
g3 him have a hard time to get my head
around that one check check and only the
Queen right check
what a game unbelievable check check
really have to be careful if I'm
blundering the Queen now as the only
piece that I can blunder White Rose eyes
she's played group g3 this is this is
really great this doesn't happen so
often to me I just as it comes like a
complete hallucination and really really
amazing yeah this is just a peaceful
form for absolutely nothing and their
plate group g3 Eddie took it yeah
unbelievable I mean okay this is what I
wanted to do as I mean I don't know I
should do whatever and it's just nothing
just a piece for nothing yeah dokie
maybe maybe can even take that one i was
i was thinking route yet but g4 you can
play him I suspected that but ok this
was the only way to to bluff a little
bit yeah and after this I'm still in the
game somehow at least we we continue
this somehow he can you blundered
blundered the change in the process
check ya hear the Queen was lost wow wow
I need to break